mein Thema heute Abend ist vielmehr der
Anstoß für eine Debatte mit unseren
anwesenden Experten es geht um den
pipeland Solar in der Ostsee am
Montagabend ist es in beiden Pipelines
Nord Stream 1 und Nord Stream 2 zu einem
starken Druckabfall gekommen die Ursache
insgesamt drei legs in der Pipeline die
Präsidentin der Europäischen Kommission
Ursula von der Leyen spricht von einem
Anschlag auf die europäische
Infrastruktur und ich weiß nicht wie es
Ihnen zu Hause geht aber ich muss sagen
bei mir hinterlässt es ein mulmiges
Gefühl Experten der norwegischen
militärwissenschaftler und Marina
offizierter strömt geht von Sabotage aus
ein Leck an drei verschiedenen Orten
können nur die Folge eines vorsätzlichen
Akts oder Sabotage sein strömen sieht
nur ein möglichen Akteur und das ist
Russland hier würde ich gerne Herrn
Professor Schlögl fragen was für ein
Anschlag von den Russen spricht oder ob
das nur Mutmaßung ist
ich habe keine Verbindung zu
Geheimdiensten es gab ja schon eine
Information von der CIA die eine Warnung
ausgesprochen hat ich habe keine Ahnung
es ist gab eine Geschichte doch
auffällig die nicht aufgetaucht ist in
den Nachrichten das nämlich an dem Tag
an dem die Explosion stattfanden
gleichzeitig oder kurz erfordert danach
die Baltic pipe geöffnet worden ist von
Norwegen nach Polen und der einzige der
soweit ich mitbekommen habe darauf
reagiert hat war modernietzky der
polnische Außenminister und das könnte
darauf hindeuten dass es eine
Demonstration der
Verwundbarkeit der wunderhabilität
überhaupt der ganzen Infrastruktur mit
der Gasversorgung ist und ich kann das
überhaupt nicht
ausschließen aber es müssen Profis
gewesen sein ein eine Prozent
durchgeführte Aktion aber wir werden das
bestimmt herausfinden und es abzuwehren
dass es die russische Seite sein könnte
dass sie kein Interesse haben könnte das
kann man auch nicht sagen sie haben in
den letzten Jahren so viele
Provokationen durchgeführt um Chaos
anzurichten und
Chaos zu moderieren dass man das auch
nicht ausschließen kann aber wir werden
das alles rechtzeitig erfahren glaube
ich Herr fragt wie prekär ist die Lager
aktuell
ich glaube die Lage im Kriegsgebiet ist
schon sehr prekär nicht also fallen die
jetzt mit Blick auf die durchgeführten
Referenten ändert das natürlich so ein
Stück weit die scheinreferenten sind
natürlich eh nicht möglich ist natürlich
Schein Referenten aber in der russischen
Perzeption
sind das jetzt Gebiete die zur
Russischen Föderation gehören und das
hat natürlich eine eskalatorische
Wirkung denn wenn da mit Waffen Gewalt
reingewirkt wird kann Russland immer
sagen jetzt wird Russland angegriffen
ist eine neue Qualität nicht und dann
kann da natürlich auch über die
Teilmobilmachung hochfahren zur general
mobil machen und diese Stichworte
Atomschlag sind ja schon gefallen er hat
dann natürlich auch wenn Russland selber
angegriffen wird in der russischen
Lesart natürlich das ist nicht unser
Verständnis dann kann er auch
tatsächlich im Waffenarsenal ganz nach
oben gehen also es ist äh sehr starke
eskalatorische
Wirkung einfach und für mich ist das
jetzt auch dieser referendin diese
Schein Legitimität der Russen und die
russische Perfektion bis jetzt Russland
das ist für mich jetzt auch ein Stück
weit ein echter Wendepunkt ich des
Krieges nicht weil wir müssen jetzt
wirklich aufpassen dass wir nicht nolenz
wohlens wirklich in einen Weltkrieg
hinein marschieren wenn wir da nicht
aufpassen und wenn wir jetzt noch mal
auf die Pipelines kommen wir wollen uns
hier natürlich nicht in Mutmaßung
verlieren noch kann keiner sagen wer es
war das auch ganz wichtig zu betonen
aber spricht denn etwas für Sie dafür
dass es ein Anschlag von den Russen war
ja also gut ich meine bei solchen Dingen
wo man kaum Informationen hat es war
eine hochkomplexe Operation das stimmt
was ja Schlör gesagt absolut diese
Stellen waren 50 km weit weg ich würde
auch sagen das waren Wochen der
Vorbereitung und die Entscheidung dazu
die ist vor Monaten gefallen das glaube
ich kann man sagen und das ist nicht von
irgendeiner Terrororganisation das waren
wirklich Profis welche Profis haben fast
alle Armeen dieser Art die Navy Seals
sind für mich die besten aber das heißt
nicht dass Amerika das war aber für
Russland ist das natürlich also irgendwo
müssen die Russen ziemlich durchgeknallt
sein wenn sie es wenn dies gemacht haben
ja wo ist das rational ich meine das
kommt für mich eigentlich als letztes in
Frage aber wir wissen es nicht das ist
jetzt reine Spekulation
Herr stellt ja wenn sie darauf blicken
was macht das auch mit Ihnen
es verdeutlicht mir einfach nur dass wir
in der Tat von erweiter Eskalation des
Krieges stehen und wir sind natürlich
Linkspartei ich meine wir halten uns
voraus wir sind durch kämpferisch aktiv
aber wir sind natürlich längst Partei
wir sind wirtschaftlich betroffen es
zeigt die Anfälligkeit wobei ich dazu
sagen muss ist bedarf durfte nicht der
Anschläge auf die Pipelines um uns zu
zeigen wie anfällig wir sind bezüglich
Energieversorgung ja das ist eigentlich
eher jetzt ein weiteres Beispiel mit
Partei bei Kriegsparteien sind wir ja
noch nicht na gut aber wir haben
natürlich
richtigerweise auf die auf die Angriff
Russlands ja mit Sanktionen reagiert wir
haben gesagt wir gehen im Prinzip mit
euch in eine waldwirtschaftskrieg hinein
wir haben gesagt wir wollen euch dafür
bestrafen wir wollen das ja aufhört und
haben das gemacht mit Sanktionen und die
Sanktionen haben wir immer weiter glaube
ich heute kommt diskutieren wird das
siebte Paket oder 6/7 Verkehr auf
EU-Ebene und dieses führt natürlich dazu
dass der Partei sind wir sagen ganz klar
wir sind an der Seite der Ukraine wir
möchten Druck aufbauen auf Russisch zu
denken wir schicken ja auch Waffen
richtig aber ich bin kein Waffenexperte
müssen halt fragen aber ich glaube der
Punkt ist einfach natürlich ist es so
wir sind dahingehend Partei wir haben
als der Krieg begonnen ist ein hat haben
wir gesagt wir sind auf seine Ukraine
und wir möchten Russland alle Anreize
geben den Krieg zu beenden und das tun
wir über Sanktionen und damit haben wir
eine ganz klare Position bezogen richtig
die Frage ist ja mir doch diskutieren
sicherlich ist ob wir auch die
Schlussfolge runter ausgezogen haben
nämlich wenn man so eine Position
bezieht da muss man auch kampffähig sein
übertragene Sinne auch jetzt nicht
militärisch sondern muss wirtschaftlich
Kampf fähig sein und es ist genauso wenn
ich jetzt hin gehe ich vor dass ich raus
zum Boxen und kann aber nicht Boxen das
ist blöd da muss ich schon hingehen muss
sagen wenn ich jetzt schon die Sanktion
mache dann muss ich mir überlegen was
wie wirkt es auf mich und wie muss ich
damit umgehen dass der Schaden für mich
geringer ist Frau Konrad angeblich sind
die Pipelines dauerhaft zerstört was
würde das für Deutschland bedeuten also
ich beteilige mich nicht an
Spekulationen darüber was genau da
passiert ist das haben sie reden
im Moment für Deutschland für die
Energieversorgung in Deutschland und im
wir müssen einfach feststellen wir haben
auch in den letzten Wochen schon kein
Gas mehr durch diese Pipelines bezogen
und Russland führt einen
völkerrechtwidrigen Angriff gegen einen
Land in Europa und es war auch nicht
anzunehmen dass noch mal Gas durch diese
Pipelines fliegst von daher würde ich
für die Energieversorgung in Deutschland
sagen spielt dieser Vorfall keine
direkte keine direkte Rolle und hat
keine direkten Folgen aber und das wurde
auch schon richtig hier in der Debatte
gesagt wir befinden uns in einem
energiekrieg der auch gegen uns geführt
wird und ja stehen harte Zeiten stehen
bevor wir treffen im Moment in
in deutschen Bundestag viele
Entscheidungen um hier die Folgen
abzuwenden doch wir müssen auch noch
weitere Entscheidungen treffen so viel
ist klar werden sie den Unternehmern
wenn es dazu kommt dass ab 1 Januar 2023
vielleicht nicht mehr jedes Unternehmen
Gas bekommt werden sie und der Bundestag
die Bundestagsabgeordneten das dann
erklärt dass es harte Zeiten sind und
jeder muss jetzt den Goethe engerstein
es wird ja alles unternommen dafür dass
auch Gas genügend da ist für überwinter
Einsparmöglichkeiten wurden früher Bezug
auch so suggeriert wurden auch an die
Bevölkerung transportiert und die
Bevölkerung und auch vor allen Dingen
Unternehmen das darf an der Stelle nicht
vergessen werden haben auch enormes
Einsparpotenzial bei Gas generiert in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten das ist
aller Ehren wert doch die Frage die sich
stellen ist ja richtig wo kommt es in
Zukunft her die wir haben die
Voraussetzungen dafür geschaffen dass
wir auch Gas in Zukunft über energy
Terminals beziehen können die sollen im
Januar das erste LG Terminal auch in
Betrieb genommen werden weitere werden
folgen das sind alles Maßnahmen die
ergriffen wurden doch die klar ist auch
Einsparung werden auch über Winter
weiter notwendig sein und die Frage die
sich ja dahinter versteckt ist ja kommen
wir in eine Situation der gasmangelage
das hängt von vielen Faktoren ab das
wurde ja auch schon in anderen Debatten
auch mit der Bundesregierung
herausgearbeitet aber die Frage ist
tatsächlich wollen wir können wir diese
diese Härten abfedern und dafür müssen
wir jetzt alles tun das muss ja klar die
Regierung hat alles richtig gemacht zu
verstehen
gemacht wurde ich glaube das kann keiner
also in der Situation für sich
beanspruchen zu sagen dass alles richtig
gemacht wurde das hier ist eine
Situation gibt es keine Vorbereitung in
der Schublade deshalb muss ich kann
Ihnen aber versprechen dass wir
dass wir auch in meiner Fraktion auf
jeden Fall alles tun und alles begleiten
und auch ermöglichen was notwendig ist
in dieser Situation